- This is what I find interesting.
You have a duet with Ariana, but you've
known her since she was little, right?
- Since she was seven years old,
Ariana Grande, there we are.
We did "Hairspray Live!" together.
I love that child.
She came back to see "Wicked."
Her grandma brought her and she said,
"My granddaughter wants to sing."
And I said, "Oh, well
that's sweet, good luck."
(laughing)
- Worldwide superstar.
- Yeah, I was like, "Okay, we'll see."
And then she sang something
and I was like, oh.
I checked myself.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because she was really good
and I said, "Here's a little wand."
Because I created the role of Glenda
and I said, "Keep that with
you and have that with you."
And she kept it all these years.
We've stayed close and I wanted
to bring her in the record
and we did "You Don't Own Me" Lesley Gore
And I'm so proud of her.
- Yeah.
- I love her.
- Oh my God, that's so cool,
(clapping) that's so cool.
- Thank you.
- It's super, super great.